[Music]
hello my name is Martin Hernandez I'm a
scientist at cloud liims and today I'm
going to talk to you about something
that has been attracting a lot of
attention in recent years and that is
the THC inflation and live shopping that
has been flagging the Cannabis industry
so well in this talk we will see what is
THC inflation we will see also why is
there so much interesting in inflating
THC and we will see also the dangers of
THC inflation for Cannabis Testing labs
and I'm going to tell you how an
informatics tool such as lims can assure
accurate testing and reporting of
THC so first let's see how the industry
is this days so the Cannabis industry
has had great achievements in 2022 that
have advanced the global legalization
agenda so with the near end of the
prohibition area comes a regulated
industry expected to be worth 82.3
billion by 2027 so that's a lot of money
that's great for the Canabis industry
but well it's not all on hunky dory
though one mayor setback has been noted
in 2022 and that is the rise in THC
inflation and the resulting trend of
laugh shopping so that's a big problem
for the Cannabis industry and the rising
of it so let's see what is THC
inflation well as it name says THC
inflation is bumping up numbers to show
that a sample has a higher concentration
than it actually has so let's say that
the low THC strains are less than 10% of
THC and the high THC strain well it's
greater than 20% of
THC so as we know the high THC strain
command a higher price so traditionally
it was very rare to find strains with
more than and 28% of THC but now it's
really common to walk into a dispensary
and find several shelves full of
products that exceed 30 or 40% of THC so
if you
notice you notice that you should be
alert that something terrible wrong is
happening that with that product so that
is a THC inflation that and well that's
a very big problem that comes to another
major problem like that is the commonly
named um laugh
shopping so what is laugh shopping well
it's the unethical practice of choosing
Laboratories based on the favorable
results that they offered some shady
Labs began to adopt this practice due to
the high demand for inflated numbers of
THC so the laugh shoing is increasingly
a serious concern for everyone and of
course this is a definitely a
consequences of THC inflations and
dishonest person that are doing
this and how does this laugh shopping
happen well it becomes when it is known
that a certain laugh is um increasing
THC levels so the Rog Growers start
flocking to the love to also increase
their THC levels and well of all all of
their products so the word begins to
spread and the laboratory is going up in
numbers
too so this practice has become so
widespread that some Labs openly
advertise their services based on the
high THC numbers on the certificates of
analysis of the clas that they generated
so they said that H great potencies they
advertise it that they they adopt this
as a marketing strategy and they are
succeeding some of
them let's see how the THC inflation is
in the US well at first the TC inflation
cases were went unreported and
consequently went unpunished so a few
cases were reported last year let's see
in AR cancas some H patients of medical
cannabis have failed a class action
lawsuit against a Cannabis Testing
laboratory for inflating uh some THC
results from three different producers
in the state and well in the west coast
two customers sued a California
marijuana company alleging that they uh
pre-roll joints were not as strong as I
claim and on the other side of the
country in Florida Regulators recently
discovered THC inflation in several
licensed medical marijuana testing labs
and there is an a study that was
published in 2021 by Dr sorof and in
this study he highlighted suspected THC
inflation in the states of Washington
and Nevada
too so now I'm going to ask you a
question does high te HC in a product
mean that is better well this is a
controversial question and according to
a study from the University of Colorado
this might not matter in the long run
because uh Beyond a certain potency
level let's say 20% it is the additional
canavs and Turpin that are responsible
for the stronger effects and not only
the THC it's a it's a mixture of the
Turpin that they have and some other
other molecules that the plant has so
let's see what this what this study says
it was really
interesting so in this study they
compared cannabis flowers users with the
Cannabis concentrates users we know that
the cannabis concentrate users are the
one that having better I mean higher
plasma levels of THC and its active
metabolic in the short term and overall
however despite this increased THC
exposure the concentrate users did not
show a greater shortterm subjective
cognitive or balance impairment so at
the end of the study I'm I'm putting
here the the DOI if you want to check it
out they conclude that not only the THC
is responsible for the effect as I said
there are some other other molecules are
responsible of it so with all this
information with all this uh research
that has been done about the THC and
their their potency so why is they
interested in inflating the
THC well first is the misinformation
about the potency of cannabis bares
because the consumers well they're not
as informed as we are in the industry
they believe that the higher the THC
content in the product the stronger or
better it will be
so high THC products command higher
pricing and encouraging this honest LA
to overstate THC potency because of
course there are money on
it so since there is so much
misinformation well the consumers are
willing to pay a higher price for
products with higher THC content and the
producers will make more money selling
the products we with this higher THC con
ation and this gives them the incentive
to inflate the THC numbers so these are
the causes of why the TSC inflation is a
big problem and it's rising right
now so in the long run the TC inflation
hurts the entire cannabis industry
because well consumers pay more for Less
poent cannabis varities they are cheated
and the medical cannabis patients who
requires product with THC at specific
concentrations suffer the biggest
consequences of inflated THC numbers so
this is too serious because we're
talking about health we're talking about
pain we're talking about a medical
issues so imagine that the doctor
prescribes you a drug whatever it is in
a certain dose you must be sure that it
is that those that you are buying at the
pharmacy so with the THC inflation you
can be sure of that so that's a big
problem for it and while the practice is
undermining consumer confidence damaging
the all the industries Integrity all all
of the chain is affected with this te
inflation so we know the Cannabis uh
industry loses credibility as more cases
of serious product leveling errors
continue to be reported and another
mayor um problem is the research itself
so the research for cannabis H is
affected when um the researchers
discovered that they cannot trust the
THC level is stated on the products
level so this is very serious as I said
because the researchers cannot continue
investigating and Publishing in journal
is they do not have the confidence and
the Rel reliability that the samples
that they studing are are confident or
are are that that concentration that it
says so the the research doesn't
continue will not continue with this
mistakes so also bad reputation the labs
that inflate this THC results May charge
higher fees yes for the extra service
that they are providing they say that
they guarantee you greater potencies for
a little extra loaded with dis honesty
so when a love is found to be inflating
this THC levels well the lab will lose
we lose all the credibility we'll face
heavy fins and even Co lose their
license and that's really good because
the social media is helping us with this
because um there are a lot of news and
there are a lot of publication of this
this honest laughs that are doing this
THC inflation so we know which labs are
so their reputation will be really bad
for them and they will lose customers at
the long
run so the honest Labs that don't play
this this honest game maybe shortterm
losers as they won't have customers
flocking on their this on their services
because they are not dishonest they will
report what it is what the instrument
says what their method that is validated
says and no anything else so they will
not have that uh of line of customers of
of very very dishonest Growers that want
an extra service they don't will
probably they will not have that extra
fee but the only clients that will stick
with them are those who believe in
transparency and the ethical business
practices and well in the long run they
will be able to build a solid reputation
and a credible clientele that will
survive for a very long time so as my
favorite group says ABA the winner text
it all so keep doing what you're doing
you you will win at the long run you
will have the best reputation you will
have you will be confident for your
clients for the researchers for the
customers so keep
doing and so why there is a scope of THC
inflation well in the absence of an
industry standard for testing Labs use
uh different processes and equipment for
testing cannabis products delivering
different results so this it's a
loophole that the Shady Labs explore to
deliver inflated THC numbers so it is
very common to have different um results
from One Life to another because there
is not a method that has been
standardized or and there are different
instruments or different analysts so
they have to have to be different but
slightly different not that different as
the Shady laps do also the scul for
manual intervation and lack of antimated
workflows allow the scops to falsify
results and mislead authorities this is
because a lot of labs they do everything
in paper so so it's really really um
easy to crust crust um crust a result
and put in another one they use probably
spreadsheets in Excel so it's it's
really easy to delete delete um a result
and put in another one so they don't
have automated workflow so it's really
easy to to to do this to to put another
another result when it is not correct
one and the lack of industrywide
adoption of tools such as the limbs that
can flat this manipulated test results
and drive workflow automation so this is
the solution this is the solution for
all these Labs that are paper based and
spreadsheet Bas based you can automated
your workflows with the software and the
manipulation of these results will not
be possible and I will show you how in
some slides
later so how to prevent this THC
inflation well first the same samples
should be test in different labs and
outliers
reported so also this the state should
move quickly to punish Labs that publish
um inflated numbers so these are the
proficiency tests that are really famous
in the Cannabis industry they have to
the labs have to test it the different
samples and probably the results will be
slightly different but not as much as
different that if not uh probably it's
like 20 21% but not 40 46% for example
so the labs are shady or inflated
numbers will be really obvious when
their
results another one would be another
solution could be a public awareness
program that it that it's definitely
needed to dispel the myth surrounded
higher THC numbers we have to educate
the consumers we have to educate the
populations and to they have to know
that that's that's a myth the THC level
it's not the the responsible of the
effect not only not only the TC level
and also the labs must be accredited to
ISO 17025 and automated processes with
the limbs to uphold quality standards
for accurate reporting and boosting the
confidence of the consumers and the
confidence of all the Cannabis industry
also stopping rampant THC inflation in
laugh shopping seems like an impossible
task but it can be done by insisting on
a credible thirdparty testing of the THC
products so another one has to test the
same products and they have to have well
also um this similar
results also the Cannabis users should
insist on seeing the coas and verify the
credibility of the testing laboratory
here again we have to educate the
Cannabis users they have to they have
the right to know what they are
consuming so they they can ask for the
coas and they can see what what are the
Real Results that they are they're
consuming on their cannabis and avoid at
all cost that H the all the labs that
have previously been involved with this
THC inflation they will be
Mark they will be flaged as uh dishonest
labs and that not reliable Labs with
really bad reputation we have to do it
we have to um we know who are them and
put it on The Black List because that's
that's not honest of
them also the industry stakeholders
should perform checks on the Cannabis
products to determine if claims of
product labels are verif Fable and of
course and I think that this is really
really important and probably the most
important at this moment is a
standardized regulations for example in
California a standardized cannabis poeny
method has mandated under the Senate
Bill 544 and it was announced on July
2022 so this is a big step to H prevent
this THC inflation with methods that has
been standardized and validated and they
doing in old Labs so they must have
similar
results but well there are some
challenges for the for the Laboratories
and this are that the Laboratories
sometimes can in that Burly report
inaccurate THC results and this may be
because some of the mistakes that can be
sample mixups or transcription errors or
the same that they're not um
standardized methods so probably there
can be a mistake there and well this
mistake can be costly and they can and
can compromise the lab's reputation
because we don't know if that was um an
advert an advertently um mistake or it
was
um well it wasn't a mistake at all they
they are uh well inflating their THC
level so we don't know if that
was so how to overcome with this
challenges and take care of the
laboratory reputation
well laboratory information management
system or a limbs supports maintaining
the highest level of accuracy and
productivity in Cannabis Testing how
well why a limbs well because a limbs
maintains Ron audit Trail and boosts
data defensibility manage QC samples and
test results Drive automation
through instruments and software
integration and generates verifiable
custom coas I'm going to show you
how first with the limbs in place manual
manipulation of data is not possible why
because the rate only audit Trail limb
tracks all the laboratory activities
such as um changes made of documents
sample records or test results and even
the login activities of the
staff here it is even with the login
activities of the staff so H with the r
only audit Trail you won't be able to
cross any result you won't be able to
delete in a spreadsheet and put another
one no no no everything is automatically
and we will know exactly who is
manipulating this results who is um who
is doing what so you will have total
control of your laboratory so this
mistakes won't happen because everything
is automatically they will eliminated
all the human errors so that's the best
choice to avoid any THC inflation issue
in your
laboratory also we know that quality
control is of vital importance for
Cannabis Testing Laboratories to
demonstrate that their results are
reproducible are reliable and defensible
so the labs use different types of
quality control sample such as method or
laboratory fortified blanks or spikes or
duplicates to test if the results are
accurate or not so Labs should validate
each test test run by comparing the test
result of the quality control samples
with the test samples and I to identify
and prevent any analytical errors so you
insert them in your samples for example
a spike and you processes everything at
the same way following your method and
if the Spy gives you the known value it
is a fact that the method was carried
out correctly and there is no doubt that
your samples have the reported THC value
so alms helps manage the results of QC
samples and flx the
errors instrument and self Integrations
we know that the Cannabis Testing Labs
performs testing of the several samples
on a day-to-day basis so the manual
transfer of analytical data from an
instrument to a limb is error prone and
reduces laboratory efficiency we know
that the end at the end of the day after
an analyst retired the last that you
want to do is to copy the result from
the instrument manually to um a
spreadsheet or anything so it's it's it
you can have a mistake there so for
minimizing the test turnaround time and
for maintaining this data Integrity it
is important to automate the data
transfer process so a good limbs can be
simply integrated with analytical
instruments for data transfer from
instruments to a lims so reducing this
turnaround time and eliminated the
chance of transcription
errors also an Erp collects stores
manage critical business metrics and
supports business operation of testing
Labs an Erp also helps to address
reability and compliance issue faced by
this uh testing labs and alms can also
be integrated with a third-party
software such as a villing software to
streamline business operation and
centrally managed critical business data
so everything will be complete uh in
your
lims and also limbs helps you to
generate certificate of analysis that
will be customs with a QR code to Ena
enable easy um authentication so this QR
code can be configured to encode a link
to uh the original COA generated by a
laboratory for example a customer
purchasing cannabis product from a
dispensary can scan with his um with his
phone on the COA and match the reported
composition with the composition on the
product label to ensure that the product
that has the same composition as claimed
so it is really helpful to increase the
confidence in your
laboratory so let's see all the the key
takeaways that we had in this talk and
we saw that the TS inflation and lab
shopping
are and we also saw the inflating power
results offers shortterm Financial gains
but we know that the end of the the long
run will be a lose for them we also
check that random testing by
stakeholders can expose some um
unscrupulous practices in your La such
as a THC inflation and the reputable LS
that do not pump the THC will earn the
trust The credibility of customers over
the time remember the winner text it all
and how alms enables laughs to ensure
accurate THC concentration reporting and
follow quality standards with ease
that's everything that we saw in this
talk so thank you very much for your
attention